I'm joined today by Dan Hyman who's a
reporter for Public News Service Dan you
were at the center of a controversy that
sort of went viral a few days ago you
were actually arrested for asking a
question
apparently at a volume and with a tone
that not everybody liked - Health
Secretary Tom Price it's been picked up
by a number of news outlets and you've
been talking about what's going on so
first and foremost let's talk about what
what's your typical beat as a reporter
well I'm based in Charleston West
Virginia and I've I've been with the
public news service since 2009 and I've
always covered West Virginia we covered
state-by-state in that time I've also
covered other states um but but I've
always covered West Virginia so talk to
us about the circumstances under which
Tom Price was going to be what you were
going to be covering Tom price and sort
of what the event was and how the
situation surfaced well I was working on
a story about the impact of the Trump
care the Republican health care proposal
on victims of domestic violence I was
already working on that story and I had
been you know been trying to gather some
information about this and saw that
secretary price was going to be in town
for something unrelated and was going to
be at the Capitol so I decided to go
down and see if I could get him to
answer a question about this
specifically whether or not domestic
violence would be considered a
pre-existing condition because before
the Affordable Care Act before Obamacare
there were instances where battered
women and men there probably a few who
lose lost their health insurance because
they the domestic violence or the damage
caused by domestic violence was a
pre-existing condition so I went down to
try and get him to answer this question
so you show up down there
he given some had had he already spoken
at the time when you approached to try
to ask a question or what were the
circumstances no he was entering the
building and was on his way to a meeting
that was close to the public later on he
did I'm told answer four questions
although I didn't know about that um and
but but he was just entering the
building it's a public space and
reporters do this all the time as he was
walking down the hall I reached out my
phone to him had my phone recording and
I asked him you know this question and
he didn't say anything in that kind of
situation you're never sure whether the
the person you're trying to talk to is
doesn't want to say anything or they're
ignoring you or whether maybe they just
didn't hear you or you didn't hear their
response so I asked him a couple more
times and you know nobody pulled me back
nobody told me you know stay away from
secretary price nobody you know grabbed
my arm
um no one even really identified
themselves as a law enforcement until I
was arrested and I was I was pulled off
taken to a room at the Capitol in
handcuffs and they sent me a way to end
up in an orange jumpsuit ultimately you
were arrested for willful disruption of
state government processes what what
exactly does that mean as far as you've
investigated and and at what point did
it become clear that it was sort of the
the volume and way in which you asked
this question that caused this entire
thing I really have no idea what that
law means I mean my lawyer says that it
may be unconstitutionally vague and I I
think he may be right about that it may
have been in court basically what this
is is the law that they use to if
somebody for example is in the gallery
of the legislature during the
legislative session or interrupts and
meeting
or something and you know shout out and
you know tries to disrupt the meeting
that they can be you know arrested using
this um it's a problematic statute and
the other thing then this is something
else my lawyers pointed out that's kind
of problematic is what process what
governmental process does was i
interrupting hmm
I mean the man was walking down a
hallway I wasn't it was like he was you
know meeting with the governor and some
kind of you know during a thunderstorm
or you know is it it gives it a
grandiosity that doesn't really make
sense and and my my suspicion is is that
the police the Capitol Police who
arrested me I don't think there was any
kind of a an order come down from on
high you know keep the keep the press
away from this guy um there were some
protesters there and the the Trump
administration and secretary price has
been very tightly controlling their
public access regarding this this health
care legislation they don't really like
talking about it and damn time to get a
few with just before we move off of the
the specifics of the airlin number one
or were you sort of noticeably
identifiable as a reporter like did you
have a press pass for example or
something identifying public news
service right I had a press pass on my
chest on the lanyard and I had a shirt
on that said public News Service
now I because it had been raining I also
had a jacket on so I don't think my
shirt was visible but when the police
arrested me I told him I was a reporter
and I told them that I was just doing my
job and they arrested me anyway did you
at any point make any physical contact
with the secretary no now I was never
close enough to make physical contact
with the secretary and in fact later on
he's done some interviews he told
conservative talk show host that the the
talk-show host asked him you know was I
quote Menace
and price said no not really
he wasn't there and I barely noticed him
you know and and this step that kind of
fits because as I said reporters do this
all the time I mean if you google Tom
price you know talking to reporters and
hallways you could pull up you know
images of him answering questions
walking down hallway in Washington DC
and then there's one quote I saw that
says from from some authority I'm not
sure exactly who it is that's quoted
that you were because you were
aggressively breaching personal space
that you were actually removed quote a
couple of times from the area is that
true where you had you already been
removed before this incident no um I
think that was that's actually in the
criminal report and I think that that
may be a case of the Capitol policeman
trying to make this sound as good as
possible
I was not removed from the hallway this
all took place in the in the hallway in
one continuous more or less motion and I
was not removed from that hallway we
were all still in the same room yeah
no one pulled me back no one grabbed me
by my arm
no one pulled me away no one said don't
do that anymore on the I think the only
thing that we can assume they mean there
is because I was trying to reach past
who I assumed at the time was secretary
prices staff although in retrospect they
may have been some of them may have been
Secret Service agents yeah they were not
identified as such being well Secret
Service agents um but I was trying to
reach past them with my phone and they
were you know pushing against me and and
I was you know it did that a few times
and then I tried to sort of jockey
around the entourage to try and get a
better angle on secretary price but no I
was never removed last thing dan what
are the repercussions for you legally
now that you've been charged
with willful disruption of state
government processes well this is a
misdemeanor but it's a it's a pretty
stout one I face
I think the magistrate said a year my
lawyer said that really means six months
but there's a potential of six months in
jail and I think a $500 fine it was
$5,000 bail Wow right yeah my network
put up I think they put up 10% of that
arm but it's it's a you know it's not to
be underestimated
I don't I'm not I think most juries are
going to stand with a free press I mean
in this country we really believe in
reporters being able to do their jobs
and have your lawyers said you know
here's how you should be thinking about
the possibility of jail time if they
sort of handicapped it for you for lack
of a better term not really um I mean II
have said that we want to fight this
some of that may be because we want to
make a point but also I think he feels
like we've got a pretty good case yeah
um but he hasn't said you know if you
got a Jaeho you know here's what you
should do it would be it's a little bit
concerning the thought of going to jail
for six months but I'm not a I feel yeah
but I do feel good that we have a strong
case we've been speaking with Dan Hyman
the reporter from public news service
who was arrested for asking questions to
Health and Human Services Secretary Tom
Price Dan we're going to be following
what goes on and I really appreciate you
telling me about how it went down today
yeah stay in touch hopefully we'll have
some news when we hopefully when they
drop the charges